the bosses are not just disappointing
but are downright bad aside from some
interesting spectacle bosses that have
different issues apart from its design
like I said this game is stunningly
atmospheric and the bosses are no
exception to this but it's when you're
actually playing in this beautiful world
and fighting these bosses that you'll
start to notice all of these annoying
flaws I'm using the word annoying pretty
often in this video because it just
perfectly illustrates my feelings on
this game G I'm sure I'll use it in the
title or thumbnail the bosses have
insanely telegraphed and limited move
sets that after just a couple of
attempts you'll look like a god gameer
to anyone oblivious to how easy these
bosses can be there's also a lack of
story context with these bosses where it
feels as though the developers just
slapped a boss on a small Bridge or in a
dark room to fill up time and space just
for them to put these bosses as regular
enemies in the next area or sometimes in
the same level you fought them in